seems to me all of these issues derive
from the same
central pathology of modernity
selfishness
i think it's simple i think it's
actually a simple answer you don't need
some
highfalutin political jargon here i
think it comes down to selfishness
okay and you know that we're a bit of a
selfish culture now
we spend an entire month celebrating
pride pride the definition of
selfishness right and self
self obsession i think there's a a real
connection here
a culture that does not value its
inheritance
whether it's a financial you know money
inheritance or whether it's a cultural
inheritance
is going to squander that and it's not
going to pass anything along
to its posterity except for debt
right so this is a weird thing that we
live in a culture now that does not
leave an inheritance to the to the
future
generations it leaves debt likewise
a generation that's not interested in
the future not interested in posterity
not interested in having kids or leaving
them anything
has no reason at all to pass on their
their cultural inheritance or their
financial inheritance or anything
who cares about the history of america
who cares about thomas jefferson
who cares about any of our traditions we
don't even care about the future we
don't care
about who comes after us
the fact that we're forgetting about our
past ties into the fact
that we're forgetting about our future
and vice versa and what you have i'm
remembered of this line
from george orwell in 1984 the line goes
every record has been destroyed or
falsified every book rewritten every
picture has been repainted every statue
and street building has been renamed
every date has been altered
and the process is continuing day by day
and minute by minute
history has stopped nothing exists
except an endless present in which the
party is
always right that's george orwell
describing this
this sort of dystopian hellscape in 1984
and that description i think suits
progressives pretty well
progressives hate the past it's right
there in their name they want to
progress beyond the past
the progressives always want to topple
those statues down
and maybe even the sadder part is it
basically suits conservatives well
as well because conservatives at least
in recent years have only been focused
on the present
they haven't been focused on conserving
very much of anything
you saw this at the supreme court just
this week but
you've seen this in in recent decades
we've we've lost on
so many issues we've given up so many
things
and then there's this irony which is
that conservatives always talk about
fiscal responsibility
yet when we get into the government we
spend just as much money if not more
as the left because we're trying to
paper over cultural problems
by just spending spending our way out of
it by just having this
facade of prosperity we don't care if
the left topples all the statues and
ruins our whole culture as long as we
get a few tax cuts every once in a while
yeah not permanent ones but you know
just every so often give us a tax cut
and then that's fine well that doesn't
conserve much of anything at all and i
think it just comes down
to this myopic focus on the present not
the past not the future
not the people who came before us not
the people who come after us just us
ourselves
just this kind of selfishness
we can serve nothing